se réinventer pour continuer d'exister
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
des entreprises s'adaptent pour séduire
de nouveaux clients
c'est le cas de la ferme verticale de
veigné à l'intérieur plantes aromatiques
et jeunes pousses cultivées dans un
ancien containers maritimes
en attendant la réouverture des belles
tables ses maraîchers se tourner vers
les particuliers
aurélie renault dans un container voici
une culture dite hydroponique haye
capucine créés sont les racines des
plantes sont directement dans l'eau pas
de terre pour ces jeunes pousses dont
les cuisiniers raffolent seulement voilà
aujourd'hui la ferme verticale ressemble
à cela des étagères quasi vide
la production a chuté de plus de 95%
car les premiers clients sont les
restaurateurs on a les balles et au de
loire là du coup on passe un petit peu
la frontière mais restaurant deux
étoiles
on a comme poire
bastien gilles et qui vient d'avoir sa
première étoile et qui a hâte sûrement
d'ouvrir et que j'ai à te rappeler pour
prendre sa commande
on a le château de beaulieu on al baqara
on a on a le moule affleurer qui est
juste à côté
les jeunes pousses une garniture remplis
d'antioxydants et de nutriments un
aliment ultra saints dont la production
hebdomadaire est passé de 600 à 60 peau
l'entreprise géo pousse tous tentent de
trouver une nouvelle clientèle les
particuliers objectif capter de nouveaux
distributeurs locaux
aujourd'hui quelques épiceries et un
supermarché propose les pots à la vente
il faut qu'on puisse effectivement
développé
et retrouver dans différents points de
vente où le particulier pour facilement
trouver la micro puce qui lui convient
et on est ouvert on a sollicité toutes
les amap de la région centre et y en a
il y en a plusieurs
on sollicite tout ce qui est
regroupement de producteurs ont
sollicité effectivement aussi la grande
distribution qui sont aujourd'hui ou
envie de faire travailler les
producteurs locaux
g ou pousse tous espèrent voir son
produit sur les salades les soupes ou
les plats des tourangeaux un produit
disponible à toute saison car dans le
container il fait 20 degrés toute
l'année